hey youtubers it's Charlie I hope you've
all had a chance to see the first
episode of Star Wars rebels this video
is gonna be my top 10 moments Disney was
real nice and made the episode available
early on Disney XD and that website
last week I already did a review of that
so I'll link it in the description but I
didn't include any spoilers than that so
this video is just gonna dig into
specific moments and in case you were
wondering yes I will be doing weekly
videos for all the episodes I'll
probably try and include some movie
stuff in those videos too just because
I'll be doing Star Wars stuff already
but careful for spoilers from episode 1
if you haven't seen it yet everybody
ready here we go number 10 Star
Destroyer intro thematically I feel like
it's a requirement that every new Star
Wars project begin with an overhead Star
Destroyer shot it's just an unspoken
rule it tells you everything you need to
know instantly the Empire is a looming
presence guaranteed this is gonna be the
opening shot of the episode 7 movie 2
even in the expanded universe during the
rise in the New Republic the Empire is
still very much a threat the other
really awesome thing about this intro it
is quick and to the point no foreplay no
five-minute crawl scene I totally love
the title crawl but if you remember the
family guy at Star Wars episodes it is
ripe for parody just because it is too
long didn't read like television is not
made for that kind of stuff they'll
totally put it in episode 7 though it's
much more of a movie thing number 9 the
planet Lothal and the Outer Rim
locations I'm kind of glad that they
didn't start on Tatooine that has been
done enough it's a big galaxy let's see
some of it while Ezra is kind of a
stand-in for young Luke Skywalker he's
not that character so they're trying to
differentiate him putting it in a
different part of the galaxy it just
helps do that but yes we are thinking
the same thing you know young Luke
Skywalker meets a version of obi-wan
gets swept up in intergalactic adventure
there are only so many versions of the
hero's journey tale you can tell which
is why I can't wait for the boba fett
movie to come that will be a very
different spin on a Star Wars story and
yes they are working on a boba fett
movie just in terms of locations rebels
is gonna take place mostly in the outer
rim there will be a little overlap with
plans we saw on Clone Wars like the
Kessel spice mines I mean there are a
lot of planets in the Star Wars universe
most of them have been
at one point or another I don't have an
exact list of all the planets we're
gonna visit that's not really
information they disseminate if you're a
big fan of the comics to remember Marvel
just took back the Star Wars comics
they're gonna be visiting some new
places in those titles number eight the
sound design the Star Wars universe has
very specific sounds that just
distinguish it from other science
fiction actually most of their sci-fi
not including animes steals a lot from
Star Wars especially when it comes to
sounds I guess you could say a lot of
other things are inspired by Star Wars
it's kind of hard to get around I mean
it's been so popular for such a long
time but you immediately notice all the
little things different types of engine
sounds different blaster sounds doors
opening and closing it just instantly
makes you feel at home like it's very
familiar in a comfortable way in fact a
lot of the big action sequences were
sound mapped to sync up with the beats
in the original trilogy in the scenes
that inspired them like the speeder bike
chase or the catwalk scene from Empire
Strikes Back it reminds you just how
important the technical people in the
production are there's like an army of
sound editors and engineers that pick
through thousands and thousands of sound
effects and going after all the voice
work is done and the score is composed
and just touch things up with very Star
Wars specific things the score 2 is
amazing it's just a modified version of
the classic John Williams score I feel
like that's another unwritten law of
Star Wars productions any time you make
a new series you have to incorporate the
classic William score somehow number
seven team ghost rolls out in Central
City you can see from the nonverbal way
they pull their high stop that they've
been doing this together for a long time
there's strong team so the wild card is
always gonna be Azra the heist itself
doesn't really go down as planned but I
always love meeting teams after they've
come together like experienced teams
it's a lot of fun to watch a bunch of
strangers get thrown together and try to
figure things out but when you do a
story that way you end up having to
hijack a lot of your stories with
exposition to show them evolving as a
group where we are in rebels right now
the crew the ghost is already at their
peak so now they can just have more fun
telling mischief managed stories it's
like the more experience you have the
better trouble you can find number 6 the
ghost ship yes it is inspired by the
Millennium Falcon technically is just a
different smaller model of Corelli and
light freighter
they haven't revealed whether it's been
modified as extensively as the Falcon
but I assume so they also use it for
smuggling so it's probably been modified
I totally love how the Karelian
freighter design over the years has
become synonymous with galactic piracy
and lovable scoundrels this is just the
first episode so we will see more of the
ship in the future but just looking at
the state of things gives you a good
picture for how well the crews doing the
computer animation does a good job of
making everything feel dirty one of the
few things that I didn't like quite as
much about Clone Wars was that all the
surfaces just looked brand new I
understand why they did things that way
like it was done on purpose like
computer animation is very intensive
work so if you see something in a frame
it's because it was supposed to be there
but I just love the dirty lived-in look
that Rebels has right now it looks like
they make just enough to get by but
they're not rolling in credits or
anything it just gives the series a much
greater sense of urgency when your
characters are always searching for the
next meal number five obi-wan Kenobi
cameo he's not a main character on the
show but the holocron is an amazing
device for future cameos in terms of
Clone Wars people they have sent ahsoka
and most of the other characters are
still canon so there is potential for
them to pop up but mostly we're gonna be
focusing on the new people we met in
this episode number four Wookiee rescue
on Kessel it was a nice callback to the
original series and the Clone Wars I
know some of you were wondering who that
young wookie was supposed to be it was
not Chewbacca like in the Canon
Chewbacca is close to 200 years old at
the beginning of the original trilogy
and as far as I know they have not
changed that I know they messed with
some of the cannon but Chewbacca is
still really really old I'm kind of
hoping that situations like this where
the ghost goes and saves groups of
people gets paid off later like the
Wookiees or some other group ends up
helping them out of a jam later in the
series I don't think they were trying to
set up any specific characters with
these rookies but hopefully we'll see a
lot more wookies on the series I'm a big
fan of the race number three
agent Kallus one of my favorite new Star
Wars villains and definitely one of the
smarter ones there's this tendency to
make villains on children's shows too
silly like too easy to defeat it's done
so that children can always understand
that the heroes will win that good will
over evil rebels is a children's show
but that does not mean that the crew the
ghost always has to win you can still do
a version of the downer ending like
Empire Strikes Back and have it be a fun
show with a positive message
the Ezra prison block scene is a good
example that he gets left behind so the
stakes go up and when he's rescued it's
much more satisfying payoff and it lets
you know that Callos is not completely
incompetent as an imperial officer he in
the main villain the Inquisitor have
like this
Watson Sherlock relationship only it's
really twisted because they're evil
characters number two the Empire Strikes
Back catwalks save the big payoff was
keen and rolling up on top of the ghost
theory Lando Calrissian of him it would
have been a little bit funny but I am
glad they didn't go for any obvious I am
your father references like that would
have been a little too much like they're
trying to pay homage to the original
trilogy
they're not trying to copy it I did love
the dated like callous kick that
stormtrooper off at the end and my
number 1 moment meet the Inquisitor
another great original trilogy nod to
Vader's Hollow calm with the emperor in
Empire Strikes Back will actually meet
the Inquisitor in person in the next
couple of episodes and some of the clips
they've been posting online of him
fighting Kanan are from much later in
the season I think this one is from
episode 6 the character is being voiced
by a lucius malfoy which is totally
appropriate Dave Filoni described the
character as being like an evil Sherlock
Holmes when he said that I was a little
confused I wondered why he didn't just
say Moriarty but I suppose that Moriarty
and Sherlock aren't really perfect
copies of each other like Moriarty
revels in chaos so I think that by
calling the Inquisitor an evil Sherlock
felonious means that he's a genius
detective that loves solving cases like
he's not out to burn down the galaxy or
mass murderer civilians Darth Vader gave
him a case and he's solving it one Jedi
at a time we can talk more about him
whenever he actually shows up in an
episode for real and like I said he and
his assistant agent Kallus have this fun
Sherlock Watson relationship so it's
gonna be really exciting let me know
though what was your favorite moment
from the premiere and which Clone Wars
characters do you really want them to
bring on I know everyone really wants to
soak up but there are a whole bunch of
other people that they could do
just as a bonus I guess I didn't mention
it in this video but I talked about in
my review there was that speech at the
end that Kanan obi-wan Kenobi speech
like they basically gave him obi-wan
Kenobi's speech from Episode six I just
I didn't want to repeat myself because I
talked about it a lot in my review video
my next rebels video is gonna be another
bonus video they're basically airing the
premiere again I think on October 13th
that's a Monday it's gonna be a Monday
show but be sure to subscribe to get
everything
if there's anything specific to rebels
that you want to talk about or Star Wars
related just let me know and I'll try to
include it in my bonus video list right
now click here for my review of the
episode and click here for my Korra
video from today who else is happy that
that show just came back thank you so
much for watching so let's all high-five
and get ready Doctor Who tomorrow see
you guys